hi everybody welcome I'm Peggy Greece
Wagar the interim executive director and
it's my pleasure to welcome you to
Joseph silifke Center for Jewish life at
Yale we are fortunate that our guest
Michael Friedman chose to speak at the
silifke Center today during his visit to
Yale and to share his Jewish journey
with us also joining us today is silifke
board president David's lefke could give
us a wave I would like to thank David
for his tireless dedication to silifke
Center we are also delighted to have
with us
Eric Fingerhut president of hello
international I would also like to thank
Eric and Hillel international for their
generous support which allows Jewish
life to flourish at Yale now our plan
was to have a student introduce Eric
since we are a student driven
organization but he had to cancel at the
last minute the good news is but I have
known Eric for almost 30 years so I
guess I can jump in and take care of
this job Eric and I little known fact
actually met on the singles mission to
Israel in 1991 we were both from
Cleveland and that's all I'll say about
that trip but what I can say is that
Jewish life has been important to Eric
for as long as I have known him he
graduated from Northwestern and Stanford
Law School but his passion was public
service Eric served in the Ohio State
Senate was a US congressman from Ohio
and was the top education chief for Ohio
as the Chancellor of the Ohio Board of
Regents for a professional who has
devoted his entire life to public
service and education with a generous
heart and a quick mind there couldn't
have been a better job than running
hello international as its president and
see
we are fortunate to have Eric at our
helm Eric will make a few comments and
then welcome Michael then Michael will
deliver remarks followed by a Q&A so
please help me welcome Eric so they
didn't tell me about the few remarks I'm
happy to welcome Michael
but before before I do that I do want to
also thank Peggy Greece wagger the
interim director of the silifke Center
for Jewish life and affirm that
everything she told you is true we have
known each other for 30 years but also
add that you are so fortunate to have
Peggy's energy and passion and really
sense of love for the community which I
can already feel radiating out of this
building so Peggy thank you for stepping
up and helping lead us this year here at
the silifke Center and of course David
thank you for your leadership of the
board and please thank all of the
leaders who make this program possible
and of course I want to say thank you to
the students who are here now for your
leadership
because as Peggy correctly said this is
your community and our job is to make it
possible for you to build the kind of
community here at Yale that you'd like
it to be and to begin the journey of
building Jewish communities so we not
only thank you for your leadership of
this Jewish community but we tell you
that we hope and pray that you will be
leaders of Jewish communities for the
rest of your life as you proceed through
your professional and personal journeys
that you'll be facing Hillel is truly an
international organization which is why
I don't have to come in separately about
Michael because operating in 17
countries on four continents in over 600
different locations
hillo is truly the central address of
Jewish life for college
and for young adults around the world
and that's really what has brought us so
close to you Michael and to your
philanthropy and your passions over the
years so I'm gonna do two things here
one is give you his official biography
because I know that that is important
for us to understand not only in this
room but also for those who are watching
us now but then but then also make sure
we understand the real impact that I
have seen Michael Friedman and his work
make on the world
so Michael freedom is an international
businessman investor and philanthropist
who is a co-founder and member of the
board of directors of the Genesis
philanthropy group which is how I've
come to know him Michael was born into a
Jewish family in Ukraine graduated from
school in 1980 where he won the School
Olympiads in physics and mathematics
after graduating from one of the top
universities in Moscow he started a
career as an entrepreneur together with
several partners he's build private
businesses from the bottom up in retail
banking and telecommunications
insurance and water Michael is a
co-founder of letter one and
international investment business
headquartered in Luxembourg with offices
in London and New York letter one has
around twenty three billion dollars
under management and buys and builds
investments internationally in the
energy telecoms and technology health
and retail sectors letter one also
invests in private equity funds and most
recently bought the UK retail chain
Holland and Barrett from the nature's
bounty and the Cal I of Group for almost
two billion euros Hollander Barrett is
one of Europe's largest health and
wellness retail chains with stores in
more than 1,150 locations worldwide he's
also a co-founder of the a/b HH group
based in Luxembourg which invests in
banking groups which provide retail
banking services in Europe and the
former and former CIS Michael is a
member of the International Advisory
Board of the new york-based Council on
Foreign Relations the founder of the
International Jazz Festival in labove
which is now one of
Europe's top ten jazz festivals he's an
active supporter of Jewish causes around
the world he co-founded the Genesis
prize which is awarded annually in
Jerusalem and I recommend that you all
go it's an unbelievable experience and
has been dubbed the Jewish Nobel by Time
magazine
he's also co-founder of the Russian
Jewish Congress which is an affiliate of
the World Jewish Congress that's
Michael's extraordinary accomplishments
how I know him
is that he has understood that Hillel
through its reach across the world plays
an important role indeed a central role
in helping each generation of Jews find
their own voice and their own journey
into Jewish leadership and into Jewish
communal life and as a result what began
as a singular partnership first in
Russia and then expanded throughout the
rest of the Soviet former Soviet Union
republics has now blossomed into a
global strategic partnership between
Hill International and the and the
genesis philanthropy group to support
and help us connect to russian-speaking
students and families and their friends
on campuses all around the world so as
to help us build a single Jewish people
for the future and for the next
generations and I will say that given
his business accomplishments Michael
we've learned a lot from you the work in
Hillel Russia has formed a model of how
we measure and how we are assured of
quality in our work all across the
global movement so we thank you for the
the leadership that has come from the
hills that the genesis philanthropy
group supports and has become now part
of the daily work of Hilo's around the
world we all know that it in the Jewish
tradition we have taken our Torah we
have taken the Old Testament and we've
divided it into weekly readings that we
call partial weekly sections of the
Torah reading and it's particularly
appropriate that we're having this
meeting today and that we're going to
get to hear from you Michael this week
because it's really the story of the
birth of the Jewish people this week is
left Luca
which famously begins with God speaking
to Abram and telling him to leave his
home and land of his father's in his
father's house and go to the land that
that God will show you it's a it's a
proof that all Jews come from the same
origin we all come from the same
beginning and there's a promise made in
la flaca at the very end when God says
for Hakeem ot at Bri T vania vania
veins are acha acha acha the door tom
God promises to establish a covenant
between God and between Abraham and his
children and all generations after him
for all time as an everlasting covenant
what I want to say particularly Michael
is that we know that there have been
moments in history when forces of the
world have tried to break that covenant
and one such time of course was during
the time of the Soviet Union when the
forces that be decided that somehow they
could break that historic promise that
generation to generation promise that
God began with Abraham in this week's
tour reading and promised to continue
forever but when the Soviet Union fell
it took a very special kind of
leadership to begin to step in
immediately and restore that covenant as
we know God has always taught us that
well the God could help create the world
and make the promises it takes human
beings to help finish that work what you
have done personally and what your
philanthropy has done to the Genesis
philanthropy group and Genesis prize is
to restore that covenant for all those
for whom the access to it had been
barred and now to help build the
relationships all across the world
between russian-speaking Jews and the
and the global Jewish people is really
something that I believe history will
look down upon and I think I think
Abraham would look down upon and say
thank you for helping us restore that
connection so it's with great pleasure
that I introduced to the silifke Center
Michael Friedman
[Applause]
so pleasant worth about me thank you so
much and a great honor and pleasure for
me to be here and actually we just
started to talk with American presidents
Holloway and other distinguished member
of slavka Center that just how many Jews
actually right now students of y'all and
it's very kind of interesting answer
that's probably it's around like 12.5%
officially according survey which kind
of attribute students iconic where
religious identity and 12.5 was
attributed as a Jews has you know kind
of believer in in Judaism means that
probably much more people who are Jews
by rail region and not effectively
admitted himself as a Jewish people and
that's interesting and symptomatic
issues seems to me for the modern world
as Eric mentioned I grew up in there in
a Soviet Union I was born in the Western
Ukrainian city called live off it's very
historically tightly connected with the
Jewish history city and one of the most
Jewish probably city in the world
before the Second World War in 1939 more
than 30 percent almost forty percent of
population of lured Jews it was probably
more than 200,000 inhabitants of this
city after Second World War and probably
those dozens of synagogue there and so
on after the Second World War
less than hundred nine hundred thousand
hundred Jews survived in this in this
city and the whole effectively history
of Jews was almost finished in the city
when after the war certain
amount of Jews including my parents came
there from the other territory of Russia
and Soviet Union and Ukraine and again
the certain extend the life of Jews in
the city started again it was a very
different in difficult time effectively
religion as a whole and particularly
Judaism Jewish religion was more or less
prohibited there is no one synagogue at
that time
despite probably 10% of population still
still has Jewish Jewish connection and
in my childhood in my boyhood I would
say there is no any symbol or sign of
Jewish life for me personally for my
parents who was absolutely secular
Soviet people an engineer except maybe
once per year my grandmother brought
matzah from from somebody who did it at
home it was impossible to buy it in a
shop that was also prohibited so that
was kind of a handmade matzah which is
whether it was quite tasty as far as I
could recall it so and first time I went
to see me so I completely was out of
Fame Jewish rituals I didn't have Bar
Mitzvah I didn't have brief Mila or you
know my my my you know maybe the food
was quite far from from from kosher
especially living in Ukraine where is
the most popular food is pork and also
there from that point I never been
anyhow connected with a with a Jewish
tradition and I definitely haven't been
in synagogue because I as I mentioned
there's no synagogue in this city in
that time on what on the other hand
because you know our you know Authority
remind us who we are
every single day it was almost official
prohibition for certain for certain
University for certain job position for
certain K type of care
for instance political carrier or it
means administrative carrier it was
clear that we could not get certain
level of you know of our you know kind
of ambition and because of that and to
certain extent this type of operation
and and discrimination you know keep
alive Jewish community and Jewish
identity because we always remember who
you are for instance for my for my
parents and it was prohibited I mean
almost officially to leave the country
and therefore my parents and never would
never know me being abroad until I
became kind of health and the time has
changed time has changed in the 80s
since appearance mr. Gorbachev as a
president of Soviet Union and the whole
situation became faster changed first
time I've been in synagogue when I went
to Moscow when I was 17 by the way it
was also a bit risky because if somebody
could see that you are visiting
synagogue you could easily would fire
from the University so that was kind of
type of military operation to be there
so nobody should see you there and
things like that so that's that's that's
that was my mind so I always felt as a
Jew because I mean I knew that I have a
lot of limitation in this life but I
didn't know at all what about due date
fortunately in middle of 80s and end of
80s the energy situation has changed
political situation and it become more
liberal more open society became as you
probably all of you knows and I'm first
time read kind of Old Testament I mean
Torah and you know and what I was
wondering you know that actually for me
that was not a religious kind of text
first of all which is probably very
different from people around for me it
was primarily and I kind of literature
about the very typical Jewish character
and what's interesting that the
character which was described
Endora Abraham Jacob Joseph you know
Isaac Moses all of this character was
very very recognizable you know it was
very similar to friends of my family
relatives in oh brother so on and a few
we're patient
we're passionate vibrant you know
characters very typical for Jewish
behavior and for me it was a kind of
important point of changing my attitude
toward Judah for me to dismiss rather
not and necessarily religious or it all
behavior is actually philosophical
ground for living and I consider myself
as a believer but not religious person
because you know for me it would be
quite quite unusual you know to follow
suddenly a certain tradition which I
never got before before it when I was a
young kid but to follow certain
philosophical and ethical pattern that
probably would be very very important
and natural so I actually believe that
according to my experience and that was
probably one of the reason why we
started so actively be involved in
Jewish philanthropy one of the reason
get too full of all this kind of
tradition of Jewish philosophy all
traditional Jewish values and principles
would be probably one of the most
efficient way to be successful in your
life in all aspects of your life not
necessarily just in care not necessarily
in business but even in your personal
life and I think that the principle of
Jewish life which forged was in the
thousands of years of Jewish history
actually one of the most efficient way
have to get a success in all your
endeavors and
I think that right for the time being we
are facing new challenges yeah we're
very fortunate to live in a period when
actually all these limitations and
discrimination steadily disappearing
especially in there let's say Western
world especially in a country like the
United States and it's very good news
for people who living today where I feel
as absolutely equal to anybody else and
it's a great that's a great success and
a great luck for us if you living of
we're living in a period of tolerance
and live a period of severe fighting
SCANA for being different form but at
the same time talking about that we
think that I think that it is very
important to find the way have to
preserve Jewish indemnity because
probably this old discrimination
oppression which our people came through
a certain extent preserve Jewish
community was in the you know generation
was in the thousands of years of Jewish
history right now they are facing new
challenge which means assimilation which
means that said modern society would
like to embrace Jews in you know and and
welcomed well and a certain extent it's
a huge temptation for Jews become just
regular American European German you
know and the British and so on which is
okay but at the same time I think it is
important for us to find a way have to
have to retain Jewish identity have to
retain all this philosophy historical
heritage knowledge and and and
principles which was extremely fruitful
and successful for thousands of
thousands of genius Jews who contributed
a lot for the for the modern world I
think that's a that's a challenge and
that's a goal for us and for you guys
who living now and who will succeed us
as a next generation of Jewish leader
and that's why it is extremely important
and pleasant for me to be here
in silifke society which is from my
point of view one of the flagship of
modern Jewish life so thank you very
much for the Dacian thank you so Michael
yeah I guess I might now if you'll have
a seat here
then we will have a little Q&A
discussion and involved the students yes
okay so I thought I would start off with
the first question so you mentioned a
little bit about what sparked your
Jewish journey once you are able to
express yourself more openly in Russia
was visiting the synagogue could you
tell us a little bit more about how your
discovery of Judaism unfolded you know
actually you know definitely living in
my you know alien ages I lived in a
Jewish environment we did not know that
it's called Jewish environment because
effectively that was just a circle of my
friends of my parents and relatives and
you know and so on and I so what I
understood in that time the kind of the
rules of behavior and tradition not the
certain religious tradition because as I
said we almost lost all this religious
tradition but generally like you know in
a day to day life it's a bit different
from people who living around right and
it was not kind of offensive let's say
to - to the external world but it was
always clear understanding that's a bit
separate from from from from the kind of
people who may bring live my
neighborhood right so and it was never
being kind of position like we live in
respect all the other approach today if
you respect tradition of granion people
or
Russian people who live near us but at
the same time you always try to cap
certain big different way of of you know
kind of day to day
you know behavior and so on for instance
you know the good example which are
always making that when first article in
about our business activity appeared in
media my mother called me and she was
very disappointed she I mean the normal
mother probably would be very happy that
you know some articles about her son
that you know he's successful in some
Sumerian but my mother was really you
know kind of very sad she said why you
could not ask him not to writing about
you it would be much better if no
information it was a certain period of
time for instance she does not want to
you know because neighbors asked her you
know I've read about some some guy
Friedman we kill is it just Michael you
know who you know just try to hide it
you know it's I mean that's a small
example how the hawk tradition is
different how the people treated
differently you know in in similar
situation right so and I am the student
certain times despite my parents is not
completely religious at all whenever
they didn't read Torah we don't know
about this but inevitably the the
holdest experience knowledge of
generation was implemented in where
day-to-day life and where habits and
where tradition you know kind of
assessment of certain values and what
what is good what is bad you know how we
should
for instance my mother always thought
look you should understand clearly you
should you should be much better than
whoever else many times to reach the
same level of you know kind of success
as anybody else because you will always
have a kind of huge you know obstacle
and and barrier and problem and I am
sure that more or less in each Jewish
family in Soviet Union and all across
the globe Jewish might be saying more or
less the same issues right I think that
was the understanding of this
understanding of you know of principle
on which
Jewish culture Jewish philosophy rely
that was the the main puff for me and
I'm sure for many other people to
recognize a Jewish identity you know in
our particular part of the world right
because we didn't have an effect on
traditional way to know about Judaism as
many of you have here in the United
States or somewhere else so and that's
why when I first time went to synagogue
that was just rather symbolic act to to
to be attached to certain kind of ritual
part of Jewish life but you know growing
I understand better and better that all
my values all things which I inherited
from my parents and from Grandma and
grandparents from before it was exactly
based on all this philosophy and
traditions and one of feeling which I
had at that time was that you know in
certain period of time I started to
think that I'm kind of linked in a very
long long chain you know which is
started you know hundreds generation ago
and still continued and certain moment
of my life I decided that I will be not
the last one I would like to do that on
my personal position that the chain will
continue you know so that was probably
for me at least my way to become a Jew I
want to open it up to students what
challenges do you and Genesis assess
Jewish communities in Ukraine and Russia
face today that's exactly what they
already started to talk I think that
fortunately for the time being this
official anti-semitism is more or less
over we don't know for how long we hope
that it for forever but right now it's a
good luck for all of us living today
that is official oppression is you know
just read next and finish
that's a good news bad news that because
of lack of connection with the Jew days
with the religion there is no any
serious denominator food for people were
Jews by their blood was with this
Jewishness
we don't know any languages effectively
a dish you know disappear
I mean Germans during Second World War
killed six million Jews and it was a
idea of final decision of Jewish
Croatian we didn't succeed but
effectively they almost killed Eastern
European Jews I mean no language anymore
all my grandmother and grandfather speak
to each other only either this just
languages not exist you know couple of
Nobel Prize winner wrote their books an
image that's language is dad we don't
speak Hebrew because we are not it
we are not religious so we are not going
to see mango I mean most of our most
vast majority of Jewish living and Jews
living in Russian grain today because
we've been cut from the tradition within
almost 80 years and generally society
become less religious more secular
that's a kind of common problem for for
the whole world right from the United
States as well so what effectively
connected us with the with the
Jewishness I would say it's just the
history probably Holocaust one of the
huge denominator for many of us Israel
probably but you know probably better
than mean it's a lot of a lot of
criticism towards israelian policy and
and then the kind of you know human
rights things like that which has become
very sensitive and very often I've
listened that especially from American
Jews that I'm a proud do but I do not
want to have any sympathy to Israel
because I don't agree with the way they
were the policy of this country and and
things like this so I think it's very
limited amount of common denominator for
among the Ukrainian Russian you know in
many other places Jews were they were
they wear a Jewishness except the
specific names and certain memory about
where past about where predecessor
hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo sacrified where life
effectively for being to being Jew right
and I think it is important then I think
that challenge for our generation to
find some new method and new denominator
have to to make people remember to
remember them who we are you know what
what for were a predecessor who have
grand grandparents you know paid so huge
huge breaths effective and probably it's
it's your goal as well
um the woman on the Burberry in the
burgundy hey so you lived in both the
vuelven and Moscow during Soviet times I
was wondering if you could say a little
bit about how the experience of being a
Soviet Jew was or was not different in
in Louisville from the way it was in
Moscow it's a good question I would say
I mean it was quite similar life I mean
actually Soviet life was very
egalitarian you know that was a main
kind of ground philosophical ground of
Soviet socialism to make egalitarian
approach for for everybody for
everything I think that the distinction
was that in the wolf it was a bit more
Jewishness General in the city because
of tradition because of more kind of
tightly connected Jewish community it
was really relatively tiny see they were
like you know so it was like 10% of
population it was a huge a huge portion
of population it was much less than it
was before the Second World War but
still it was quickly pretty important
and the certain extent this tradition
were alive at that time and you know
local people they remembered of Jewish
presence in this city you know we know
it always been city of Mary many
different ethnic oh let's say tried you
know it was a city of Polish people
Ukrainian Jews Russian Serbian Armenian
so on that was it you know kind of part
of hansel trading city and people
understand understood you know the
difference between different you know
ethnics between different religious
group and very treated each other more
professionally let's say we understand
very spected each other way within the
more accurate about Moscow from that
point were
was very different must was capital of
Russian Empire historically and that was
Russian seeking definitely Jews didn't
play important role in this city you
know as you know until 1917 the
so-called pale land line of favoring the
Paracel it was a kind of impossible
legally to live in Moscow so they
effectively Jews appeared in Moscow
after after revolution and they actually
became tiny minority and this is very
important minority because as you know
in the first period of Soviet power Jews
played extremely important role there
but it was minority and then I mean and
also what is important that again of
Jews who became Soviet leader Soviet
kind of made so via type of success way
tried hardly to forget about where
Jewish rules they always try to be
fortunately there's a kind of Soviet
people you know because it was much more
comfortable for making a carrier at that
time so I would say Moscow was not at
all Jersey that was just kind of city
within you know certain amount of Jews
living and with not trying to to
demonstrate their Jewishness no from
that point was a bit different
so but but but it still was very very
similar country with the similar type of
you know politics you know concept
slogan salary everything more or less
you know food in the main and the shops
and the restaurant
every restaurant have the same menu for
me that was quite unusual that exists
some different type of cuisine model is
the same with a with a with a with a
different ethnic groups
okay let's see what's on the mind of
more students first off thank you for
being here
so in your remarks today you you've
talked about the importance of Jewish
identity Jewish culture Jewish
philosophy and its impact on Jewish
success throughout history so from your
vantage point as someone who's achieved
great success yourself what are some of
the key ideas from Jewish culture and
thinking that have most contributed to
Jewish flourishing and success very good
question you know I think again I do not
want to argue with a with a religious
kind of concept my guess that Jew
Judaism and Jewishness as a kind of
phenomena is a phenomena of minority who
would like to stay as a minority you
know it's in for the normal human being
it's very natural to have a intention
and desire to join the majority because
to be in the minority is always
challenging right it's always
uncomfortable you know if you're
analyzing history of Jews and I mean
just you know if you're another history
of mankind
well hundreds of different nations and
you know for instance in territory of
let's say Russia Soviet Union just 500
years ago lived dozens of different
nation we don't even remember names of
this of this nation and tribes right so
we all of them effectively assimilated
and disappeared and became more or less
you know unified majority of let's say
let's call Russian them or the same
thing in any place in Europe in German
differences 17th century that was dozens
of different states in this territory
with a different tradition and different
tribal characteristic and so on
right now it's Germany renewing as a
Germany why it's happened because
effectively you know you know if
somebody won the war
you know effectively that he implements
my own tradition and values and religion
very of them and effectively people join
this because we believe that it's more
stronger more efficient way of living
Jews one of the unique nation which
which which which came through the
thousands of years of history survived
as the Jews living in the surrounded by
their all other tribes nation and
culture but still keep their own
traditions values and you know and and
and you know religion and I think it was
a huge temptation for many of em to join
majority right and probably pleasurable
part of Jews historically you know
assimilated and just very kind of tiny
minority kept their own path in our own
way of thinking of doing something of
everything and stubbornly I would like
to stay as a minority I think that that
that's that's that creates very
important features of Jewish character I
mean you know to be a minority to be so
stubborn it's it always requests a lot
of aspiration you know and to be ready
to challenge every single day and I
think that was transformed were
transformed to decision I transform to
very typical Jewish approach to many
kind of aspect of human activity in a
science in arts everywhere you know Jews
always on a cutting edge of changes
we're always trying to to challenge you
know we never agree with a certain kind
of proven wisdom we always would like to
undermine this this kind of proven
right so we're always trying to to
change perception about something you
know look for any and I think and I
think to a certain extent that's
connected with the history and with the
values which typical for Jews you know
no authority well no moral authority no
no no no no no no legal authority just
you know we're own you know kind of
challenge and we all desire to achieve
our own goal I think that's very
important characteristic which allow for
men who just become so successful in
many years and look even even now the
whole this high tech industry look for
Israel in audits amazing because that
will require always not be agreed with a
kind of traditional approach and I think
the certain extent that's already very
deeply implement and the Jewish genes I
would say that's why I think it's so
important to retain because that could
make a huge contribution to to the life
of the whole you know mankind
thank you thank you very much like you I
was born in Ukraine and Odessa and a lot
of my family that came over here are
very conservative and voted for Trump
one of the presidential candidates this
year was Jewish didn't very spoke
against the conservative more a
tradition jumping off of your point
where you were talking about fighting
against mostly conservative traditions
of the past how should where does a
Jewish philosophy advocate for us to go
forward should we assimilate against a
tradition or should we bond without
other minorities Allah Bernie Sanders
I definitely do not believe that we
should assimilate I think it is great I
think we should find a way half on one
hand to be part of modern society to be
part of non-sena phobic tolerant
open-minded society on the other hand to
retain our specific our uniqueness to
certain extent and to treat it - to
preserve our ability to make this world
much better place rather than it was
before and I think you know religion in
that in the mean could play important
role again as a kind of contribution of
values I don't necessarily believe that
you know future of Jewishness just about
religious people I don't want I could
not imagine that the kind of future of
huge community would be just only
hydrogen who actually Orthodox believer
I think we should find the kind of
golden middle between being attached
with a tradition at the same time to be
open minded for for for modern mostly
secular society
I don't know precise answer for this
equation we're trying to find
I mean Genesis philanthropy group the
main the main goal for this it's tried
to find what is there what is the best
method to keep this balance and we be
considering probably connection with
Israel should be very important part of
Jewish identity we believe that you know
culture which is quite unique you know
and we could find some girls can
concrete example of any class of Jewish
culture which is this make a distinction
between Jewish culture and culture many
other nation could be kind of this this
element which will keep Jewishness and
life
but we definitely don't know you know
very kind of final answer on that
question and I think again that's the
challenge we are facing right now and I
think depending of how you guys will
answer we respond to this this challenge
that very heavily input for the destiny
of Jewishness Michael thank you so much
for being here and first of all I just
want to say hearing your story and as
someone who went to day school my whole
life it's just really inspiring it makes
me realize how amazing of an opportunity
that was so last year I was the
co-president of the student body at the
hello and oftentimes I would go around
and talk to students the 12.5% but
mostly I would try to talk to students
who are the part that we don't reach of
those you know 12.5 percent of students
and oftentimes they would say something
like I really want to learn more about
Judaism and my Jewish identity but I'm
uncomfortable with the institutional
Jewish communities approach to Zionism
or Israel or Israeli policy like you
said and if someone who cares a lot
about assimilation and connection to
Jewish identity I was wondering if you
think if you know changing the
institutional Jewish community's
approach to Zionism where the State of
Israel could help strengthen Jewish
identity or reduce assimilation if you
would think that that's a reasonable
approach to solving some of these
problems and yeah thank you so much for
your time I think actually it's a lot of
I mean you know in the history of
Judaism Jews demonstrated a huge
flexibility regarding how they
interpreted you know Judaism and
Jewishness and have to fulfill religious
you know requests and you know tradition
and and from that point it's it's a
certain extent you know make me
optimistic about about future I think
that it is very important right now to
find the right way up to on one hand
preserve tradition another hand to be
kind of open minded towards modern
sophisticated and
firstly changing walk I think couple of
issues definitely will arise very
quickly I think the question of relation
between Israel and diaspora become
absolutely crucial point in the future
and I think for best success of Israel
and best success of diaspora is
crucially important to establish really
close ties and breach and connection I
think that what's happened sometimes I
mean this disappointment in diaspora
about Israel and vice versa it's hugely
dangerous for them for the future of
both sides future dangerous I think we
should undertake all our possible
efforts to restore this close ties I
think that's really I think the voice of
the Diaspora should be listen very
carefully and in that RIM in Israel and
vice versa
diaspora should better understand and be
more actively involved in what's going
on Israel to be advocating and promoting
Israeli ins and Israel is a country
outside the country outside Israel right
I think it is also very important to a
certain extent to change approach to a
couple of you know the most important
issue like for instance in
inter-religious marriage right you know
according right now it's a lot of debate
in Israel and worldwide about gee you're
effectively and conversion general I
think you know that's very important to
send a message on behalf of Jewish
society that we are open that not
necessarily mean we should change the
tradition or destroy a kind of approach
to that which require very strict you
know kind of serious efforts for for for
becoming a Jew but on the other hand it
is it seems to me and again I'm not a
religious person so I'm talking
let me help myself it is important to
send message
our tent is open so as a tenth of Habra
ham you mentioned it so we are welcome
everybody who wish to become a Jews who
seriously consider this option who who
who wish to spend time and and and an
effort to become an Jews we open for
them we are not closed society and I
would like to close our doors so you
know in couple of other I think that
that that's theological change which we
which you hugely important for the
future of Jews and I think you know
again historically Jews were quite
flexible and adoptive I hope I rely a
lot on this on these features I do not
want to even imagine that Judaism as a
phenomenon will somehow
well I think with this group in this
room we can count on it to remain strong
there's been a special and memorable
event I'm sorry we don't have any more
time for questions because I'm mindful
of Michael's schedule I would like to
just take a moment to thank Julie
Goodman our director of Jewish student
life for putting this event together for
us
Thank You Julie take this time to thank
you Michael thank you're sharing your
very valuable time with us and for
enlightening us and for making a Yale
education available for so many students
with your generous support we hope you
will be a frequent guest to the silifke
Center I hope something I know you have
to dash off to your next event but I
invite everybody else to stay for the
reception outside thank you
[Applause]
[Music]